there are always crazy things at CES
always but this might be the craziest
one it's called the e hang one eight
four and it's a cell flying drone that
will carry one person up to 260 pounds
for up to 23 minutes it's designed as a
way to go from you know your car to your
private island or for hospitals or
things like that but basically the way
it works that you get in it'll fly from
a helipad and if you fold it up it'll
actually be about the size of a floor
and it's very small
you get in you use Google Maps to pick
where you want to go and then it just
picks up and flies you where you're
going and that sets you down it's all
designed to be automatic but they have
teams of people who will actually be
watching as you go and they'll make sure
that if something goes wrong but you
still get there because self flying
drones are a terrifying idea right now
so there are regulations problems
everywhere like this it's basically
illegal in every country right now but
iing says they're working on that cell
phone and if they do this thing which is
gonna cost a couple hundred thousand
dollars if and when it does eventually
come out is going to be awesome
you